freude herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video einen neuen format auf dass
ich richtig bock haben nämlich amateur
erstes profi womit ich nicht sagen will
um den kommentaren vorzubeugen dass ich
ein profi wind ich will lediglich zwei
verschiedene zubereitungs weise zeigen
wo man sagen würde dass kriege ich im
restaurant ich finde dass das eine ziel
von 10 und das hier ist das wie jeder
der gerade anfängt zu hause kocht das
interessant wird sein wie viel ist
dazwischen wie viel aufwand ist
dazwischen und kann nicht vielleicht
auch jeder die profiversion machen so
wir fangen an mit der amateur version
wir haben die klassischen zutaten für
jeden der erstmal carbonara machte bacon
würfel gibt es ja in jedem supermarkt
schlagsahne beziehungsweise koch seinen
zwei knoblauchzehen eine zwiebel und das
hier ist das was jedem italiener
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon vor wut
kochen lässt weil klassische
professionelle italienische carbonara
kennt keine sagen kein verband in dem
ich unsere zwiebel würfeln das glück
scheint sowieso immer wie ein amateur
zwiebeln das aber carbonara würde ich
eigentlich ein sehr einfaches gericht
aussuchen gesicht was man so als
einsteiger wird man so anfängt zu kochen
mal gerne machen er wird das auch bei
mir so
klein ich will jetzt gar nichts sagen
das ist eine sache unbedingt schlecht
ist somit nur mit liebe gekocht
carbonara mit diesen zutaten ist auch
kein safe ist größer prozent gail
manchmal ich hab sogar ob diese variante
anfreunden
du hast das nicht sagen aber einfach ein
bisschen anbraten auslassen und wenn ein
bisschen von dem fed aus den schinken
würfeln rausgekommen ist geben wir dazu
unsere zwiebeln
ich habe parallel knoblauch sie jetzt
vorbereiten eigentlich darf ich das so
nicht machen man muss nur machen
weil die amateur version so aber es die
unfassbar gut niemand kann mir sagen
auch der größte es noch so dass erst mal
geht können wir nicht sagen dass das
nicht gut ist aber dass hier wird ein
anderes level heben den knoblauch dazu
bedarf es nicht getrauen werden das
wollen wir nicht gehen ein bisschen
runter auf 100 grad und geben einfach
einen becher schlagsahne druck hat sich
nochmal gut durchschütteln können
überhaupt nicht schlimm macht nix
und so lassen wir das ganze jetzt einmal
aufkochen so muss das aussehen
auftauchen dabei kann man noch mal ein
bisschen umrühren das ist ist stabil für
wetten dass wird lecker sein ich muss ja
auch lecker sein ich meine so viel fett
von der saane drin das schmeckt halt
einfach so mir das ist halt eher so eine
amerikanisierte germanisierung form von
der kabine aber keiner ist halt
italienisches gericht dass alle dass die
italienische küche einiges zu bieten hat
das schmecken wir es nur mit pfeffer und
salz ab vor allem pfeffer weil zeit ist
natürlich schon jede menge drin durch
den ganzen schenken dann stellen wir es
auch runter und kümmern uns um die profi
variante profi kamera oder wie man in
italien sagen amateur carbonara weil das
ist eigentlich die klassische römische
zubereitungs weise die herkunft von dem
rezept ist in rom und wir haben hier
keinen normalen speck das hier ist wie
ein schale
italienischer speck und man sieht hier
direkt das ist eine ganz andere qualität
der fettanteil die marmorierung werden
hier unten eine leichte pfeffer kruste
und das gute hierbei ist können die
grundschule im dickeren stücke schneiden
weil diese bacon würfel immer so klein
dass sie eigentlich schon fast ein
bisschen unter geben dass sie keine
richtige textur dazu geben hier ist das
was ganz anderes kamera ist eigentlich
auch das perfekte rezept für dieses
format also amateur versus profi weil es
ist einfach eine grundlegend andere
zubereitung so das war's man im standard
restaurants bekommen ist können jetzt
ihr das im guten kriegst du das so und
kennt ihr noch weitere dinge wo man auch
sagt peter gibt es zwei religionen so
quasi gibt es die verbreitete und die
richtige variante schreibt man die
kommentare ich kümmere mich um die
waagschale relativ dick schneiden wie
gesagt
wie butter und das ist also das ist eine
qualität dass es wirklich nicht mehr
nicht mehr normal der fettanteil oder
das pferd was wir hier dran haben ist
super wichtig so klar erkennt seite
statement des geschmacksträger ist
stimmt halt einfach aber gerade für
unsere soße ist es auch wichtig dass wir
schön fertigen schale haben wenn man das
hier so in der hand hatte die bahn
schale aus dass an den händen zurück
bleibt das erinnert mich ein bisschen an
braucht das schmilzt einfach in der hand
man das radio eine andere qualität aber
wir müssen gar kein fett hineingeben wir
machen das ganze einfach sofort bietet
hat sich einfach so schon los davon wer
das ist ganz ganz knapp mit unserer
quartale in die falle wichtig eine
unbeschichtete fahne findet man
eigentlich quasi nur so in
professionellen pisten und ihr werdet
euch gleich wundern wie gesagt die
wirklich auch hinter der kamera kein
fett hinzu was hier gleich schwimmt in
dieser panne weil das ist ganz krass
wenn wir aber keine sahne haben woraus
besteht die soße eigentlich das zeige
ich euch jetzt wir beginnen indem wir
pecorino romano einfach vierkant
reibekuchen romano auch nicht so weit
verbreitet klar kriegt man auch im
supermarkt aber ist auch schon wieder so
ein bisschen so etwas besonderes und
guckt man endlich in den pecorino gerade
angefangen haben zu raum steht jetzt
schon das fett in der pfanne
mamma mia
diesmal
ist die bibel ist das erstens schon
steht das schon zentimeter neben
pecorino von schale und einer geheim-
staat brauchen wir noch eier und zwar
beschreibt uns einen großen teller und
trennen unsere vier eier wir brauchen
nämlich nur den sechsten teil des
alltags ganz genau schnapp uns eine
gabel bequem unser eigelb und dann wird
es zeit für den star der show für den
parcours in dem wir schrittweise
hinzugeben und aufnehmen in unser
eigenes
bargeld die carbonara fehlen natürlich
noch spaghetti die pasta die
eigentlichen nudeln und natürlich haben
wir die bei der profi variante selbst
gemacht
eine portion einfach ein bisschen
mindestens 50 minuten
vielmehr brauchen wir gar nicht für
unsere profi pasta hier ist unsere
wunderschöne pasta und hier ist die
fertige überhaupt kein stehen fertige
passt das auch über sky aber frische
halt noch geiler wir geben jetzt in den
tod hinein wichtig immer teil auch zehn
minuten aber bei unserer frischen haff
käme gar kein thema stellen weil wir
haben sie ja selbst gemacht so wir sind
unser eigener teilnehmen die frische
pasta dadurch dass wir sie so gelagert
haben hält schön zusammen in das wasser
hinein mal so gut ausgedacht damit hier
nicht zusammenklebt zu beginn einmal
durchführen und das ding ist sie sieht
jetzt etwas schmal aus aber diese auch
hier noch was aus
[Musik]
während die andere passt auf dass unsere
frische pasta schon fertig war in einem
weil ich so schön lang sind wenn wir
alles aufholen und so nehmen wir jetzt
unseren an und geben die in die pfanne
zu unserer bronchiale und all den
leckeren fällt jetzt benutzen wir sie
mit dem ganzen feld von der grundschule
dadurch kleben sie nicht mehr zusammen
und können einfach schön bisschen warm
halten und hier ist sie unsere geheime
zutat nudelwasser wirklich in jedem
klassischen personellen italienischen
passt ein gericht ist nudelwasser mit
von der partie daran haben wir stärke
das gibt uns flüssigkeit das bindet und
emuliert mit diesem gemisch hier zu
einer cremigen schönen so sagt dass
pasta wasser ist ein wenig abgekühlt und
unter ständigem rühren geben wir das
jetzt hier zu unserem pecorino
abgemischten gemerkt direkt zeit wird
aufgenommen das schmerzt den corino aber
ist genauso wahr das ist eben nicht das
eigelb zum stocken bringt also es ist
einfach dadurch wer sich das ausgedacht
hat krank oder ganz ärgern wir auch
nicht lange machen die hitze aus ganz
wichtig und geben das über alles
das ist so eine dicke dichte pasta sauce
damit ist unsere professionelle partner
fertig und wir machen die andere bei der
amateur variante kippen wir natürlich
das nudelwasser weg mit den grünen
begeben unsere nudeln dazu
und becher sahne gibt natürlich auch
eine schöne cremigkeit auf geht's zum
text test
[Musik]
bis zwei portionen spaghetti carbonara
ungefähr gleicher zeitaufwand amateur
variante profi variante ihr seht schon
mal präsentation anrichte macht super
viel aus wie ein schönes nest obendrauf
die knusprigen schale stückchen wenig
schwarzer pfeffer ein bisschen parmesan
und hier drüben ganz einfach um auf den
tellern ich bin nicht unfair sein will
sondern ich will so diesen unterschied
den man durch ein bisschen mehr oder
auch teilweise in späteren folgen stimmt
auch viel mehr arbeit erzielen kann
hervorheben und da zählt eben die
einrichtung auch dazu wo gehe ich als
erstes rein in die anfänger kammer nahe
kommen wir gucken wir haben eine cremige
soße haben zwischendrin speck stückchen
keiner drin es gibt auch natürlich
amateurrennen mit aromen sich probieren
einfach mal
mehr was soll brauchen wir nun becher
sahne eine packung speckwürfel zwiebel
knoblauch und nudeln zusammenschluss
schmeckt halt gar
nicht hier um zu sagen dass das scheiße
ist also das ist gar nicht mal die
mission sehr cremig es ist sehr schwer
also wirklich so von die sahne macht
sich auf jeden fall bemerkbar aber das
ist eine carbonara die man so jedem
restaurant bekommt so in jedem standard
restaurant blickt man so wird kein
schelm auf jemanden der das so macht
also bist du nicht wenn du sie jetzt so
bewerten müsste ist trotzdem so eine art
von 10 oder so website besonders auf
jeden fall also die die nudeln sind
bekannter geschmack diese art von pastor
muss es auch gut aber wir lassen den
löffel liegen zur erinnerung keine sahne
kein nichts und da unten steht die pasta
sauce etwas unfaires mache ich probiere
so ein stückchen quartale
was soll man sagen das ist wirklich
nicht mal im ansatz zu vergleichen mit
speckwürfeln das ist einfach so viel
mehr so dieses produkt was wirklich ganz
viel dass man durch wachsenden geschmack
die werden durch knusprig durch das
anbraten unglaublich jetzt wird's zeit
unseren touren zu stürzen
weil wir die pasta selbst gemacht haben
und sich schön lang gelaufen können wir
einfach alles in einem hoch ziehen alle
unterlagen
geisteskrank ist schadet diese glaube
ich die cremigkeit von dieser gabel und
jetzt bin ich selbst gespannt was mich
hier erwartet
[Musik]
ich merkte dass ich sie aus respekt ohne
löffel esse ich bin super happy mit den
nudeln sowie haben einen geilen bis sind
aber von der textur von der konsistenz
ja ganz anders als die gekauften
spaghetti sind irgendwo weiter aber
nehme auch alles noch viel besser auf
und haben trotzdem so man hat so riecht
viel zu kauen irgendwie
das eine perfekte körper durch ist
nachher es ist eine perfekte carbonara
das krasseste es wirklich der kontrast
von diesem cremigen nudeln guck mal wie
das zusammenhält das macht keine
anstalten irgendwie auseinander zu
fallen also mein letzte kabel eric man
dazu endlich probieren
rollentausch eric ist vor der kamera
tabula nach welche macht diese carola
probieren wir erstmal die handwerker mir
war schon von vornherein klar dass es
heute nicht darum geht welche die
bessere weil du hast auch schon sagte
beide sind geil
übels geil ja das ist übel skype ist es
ist zwar das erste was ich heute esse
und dadurch noch mal geil aber gib mir
dass ich bin so richtig happy ja
ich bin am meisten auf gespannt wie gut
die nudeln sind
[Musik]
einfach todesursache
steht vielleicht das ist es geht nicht
darum was besser ist aber so gut
oder was nie würden kranke gewesen wären
rückstand kranke welt auseinander
gedacht aber die menge von fendt
auszuzahlen diese nun die sind kleine
schärfe die jetzt am ende noch übrig
bleibt einfach so muss ich muss zu
dieser art von kara sagen dass ein ganz
anderes geschmacksbild ganz anderes
profil was auf der zunge abgeht kann man
nicht vergleichen zu dieser hier ist
schon fast ein anderes gericht ja das
ist kassen wäre es noch nicht gemacht
hat muss es jetzt heute abend
vorteil von der amateur carbonara man
kann sie gut wieder aufwärmen so die
andere schon schwer mit dem eigelb drin
aber geile erste folge gemerkt manchmal
ist es gar nicht so viel schwerer ein
krankes resultat zu erzielen deshalb ich
danke fürs zuschauen ich freue mich auf
die nächste folge schreibt gerne in die
kommentare was er machen soll und bis
zur nächsten video